par alors vous jouez le rôle de michel
durand un psychanalyste et une vie
plutôt banale déjà en train de recevoir
des clients il ya catherine boucher qui
sait une prof de maths chahuté qui est
excellente dans le rôle d'ailleurs puis
à l'éjaculateur précoce qui est toujours
énervé et puis lé récit sado-maso de
d'hélène de fougerolles donc qui joue
olga kugler et qui est une perverse
cleptomane qu'elle se faire battre par
son mari qui yves rénier voilà et que se
passe-t-il que c'est vrai oui j'avais
oublié ainsi de l'émission est ce parce
que à ce psychanalyste est quand même un
peu dépressif et il est absolument
convaincu que cette cette patiente et
said éveillé en lui des désirs meurtrier
et il a la fâcheuse tendance à
s'endormir quand elle vient le consulter
et un jour il s'endort il se réveille et
elle est morte sur son divan est il à
d'horribles douleur dans les avant droit
donc voilà alors peut-on assassiner
quelqu'un endormante la première
question qu'on se pose et ensuite comme
très vite comment se débarrasser du
corps
oui et donc toute une histoire commence
une histoire effectivement très ça fait
un peu penser aux films de deux scores
sais c'est que ça plaît after hours
soliveres le type il est pris dans une
espèce de dans un engrenage comme ça
c'est un peu cet esprit là oui
absolument il y aurait la possibilité
d'appeler tout de suite à police est
finalement il fait le mauvais choix ou
le bon choix en donnant finalement à
l'arrivée on s'aperçoit que ce film
c'est aussi le parcours initiatique d'un
d'un psy d'abc au fond qui qui va régler
des comptes avec lui mais en fait son
analyse à lui parce que tu pourrais
scifo avoir fait une analyse mais lui
son analyse qu'au début du tout comment
ça finit bien final près ils obligés de
regarder les problèmes qu'ils n'avaient
pas réglé les actes - c'est ça c'est ça
l'histoire tu as fais des films psy ou
non jamais non non il était lent voire
en main pour préparer le film
oui enfin j'ai vu que j'ai pu j'ai vu
peu de gens j'ai vu une personne qui m'a
donné deux phrases clés qui l'écoutent
flottante et la neutralité bienveillante
mais en fin de compte je sais il a été
il a fait reculer les 1000 r
non non j'en ai rencontré un beaucoup
plus intéressant et et
neutralité bienveillante et écoute
flottante voilà ça c'est le b à ba du
psy ses proches en fête du travail avec
l'acteur vis-à-vis ses personnages alors
le père était vétérinaire et finalement
vous avez intégré un peu inconsciemment
les codes du en voyant ça peut-être non
les codes du passage des malades etc
oui c'est les gants qui vont jusqu'à les
merveilles oui mais c'était le soir
justement et qu'on manquait de costumes
j'avais choper des membres je ne
pourrais pas te le dire je vous ai déjà
fait des rôles de médecin faisait déjà
fait et j'ai dis moi oui
jeanne d'arc a dit il un lien d'amour de
d'auray et donc vous avez est ce que ça
vient de voler vers la cité les animaux
avec leur avec leurs maîtres et puis
j'en ai conçu surtout une très très
grande passion pour le monde animal dans
les alpes vous avez quelqu'un sait que
laurent à laurent les zoophiles c'est
incroyable comment on dit quelqu'un qui
aime bien les animaux riis à ses ciseaux
philologue mais alors jean hugues
anglade huys et laisser les faits la wii
c'est les guépards oui connaissez les
guépards longchamp du guépard tout le
monde connaît même fait tatouer les
connais tu vas devoir à laon la la
hanche
là on a dit on a dit à la femme est
venue sur mahler et les filles à la fin
de l'émission jean hugues anglade ou bon
si vous suivez toujours
voilà si vous êtes plus jour là vous
verrez le guépard de gens rigolent bien
alors vous allez retrouver hélène de
fougerolles que vous aviez déjà vu dans
trois champs de jardin est là elle a de
l'avenir vous pensé parce que tout le
monde lui prédit un grand avenir mais en
même temps elle a pas encore trouvé le
pascal meurt vite dans la roue de bélaye
c'est quelqu'un qui a l'audace pour
pouvoir effectivement brasser dépit des
personnages difficile et et voilà donc
elle est un peu l est au début mais les
vingt marins mais elle est très
audacieuse des mecs j'ai eu du mal avec
elle quand même parce que n'a pas voulu
voulu rien montré oui elle est là
elle a négocié trop mais je pense que
c'est se montrer nue n'est pas forcément
un signe d'extraversion la preuve en est
ce que moi je suis pas particulièrement
fâché plutôt timide de nature timide et
vous ferez passer de bordeaux et je me
suis mis deux nuits en déficit il assuré
vous avez une plastique exceptionnel
jolie vient alors vous avez retrouvé
beineix c'est intéressant parce que 37 2
le matin comme était un film c'est
toujours en chine culte vous l'avez
trouvé comment oui bah je vais retrouver
par hasard ce qui m'a appelé 15 ans
après un nom que j'ai gardé un tel
souvenir de 37,2 bon c'est une banalité
de que de le dire encore aujourd'hui met
d'ailleurs en j'en profite pour dire que
le dvd en version intégrale intégrale de
37,2 va sortir est déjà sorti je pense
ce que j'ai appris sur sur mortel
transfert est davantage
j'ai davantage regarder jean jacques et
la façon dont il avait évolué la façon
dont il s'était aguerris et puis la
maturité qui est la sienne aujourd'hui
son indépendance son courage parce que
faut pas oublier que ce film et c'est
lui qui l'a produit encore une fois
c'est c'est vraiment très courageux et
c'est encore la raison pour laquelle je
pense que la critique la critique était
très dur avec lui parce que elle devrait
tenir compte de la courage qui a été le
sien de produire ce film il a mis sans
argent il a mis son argent et pour une
fois qu'un producteur qui veulent pas
d'argent à lui j'ai tellement il ya un
peu d'argent de canal est un peu
d'argent réellement bon faction il a mis
beaucoup d'argent à lui voilà alors vous
quand vous parlez de votre travail
c'est vrai que c'est très différent d'un
film sur l'autre et vous dites j'ai pas
une petite valise remplie de recettes et
j'ai pas encore trop de combines je fais
le maximum pour rester vierge face à un
rôle
oui c'est vrai c'est pas marqué dans un
type de rôle particulier
non je jusqu'à preuve d'un bon acteur
comme dirait m'enfin je ne crois pas non
mais c'est pas trop à moi de le dire
ah bon mais je vous la nouvelle qui pour
le dire non mais c'est à dire que c'est
c'est un métier très très empirique
c'est une approche très très atypique
c'est très difficile et aussi
passionnant bien alors ça s'appelle
mortel transfert de jean jacques beineix
avec hélène de fougerolles jean hugues
anglade et c'est dans un cinéma près de
chez vous